[Music]
in Super Bowl aftermath news submitted
by it Maria loves the JK Cruz fantasy
anytime
experts explore the science behind why
sports fans riot after a big win oh yes
please explain that know why can I tell
you the reason why
yes toss the road cuz we're [ __ ]
Scopus thanks for watching and it's the
winners rioting right yeah wonder why I
[ __ ] love this last Super Bowl it was
a dope-ass super bit naughty gonna [ __ ]
the pets I was rooting for the Eagles
but I really found the Pats were gonna
win cuz I thought it was all setup and
rigged already you know what's so crazy
cuz [ __ ] that [ __ ] Tom Brady
has such a good [ __ ] arm even when
there's like a minute left oh my oh [ __ ]
you know oh [ __ ] they could turn it
around oh it was so good man I haven't
enjoyed a Super Bowl that much it's like
last year we really thought the Falcons
were gonna win a halftime like they were
like 24 points behind there's something
the Pats and then they I still won they
always win and we're so sick of the
winning yeah so yeah it was nice but
then Philadelphia got burned to the
ground after yeah which I didn't
understand I was like you guys won yeah
so experts are are saying that there's
many reasons why people might write it
after a win but before we get into that
I'll show you guys a clip of people
riding in Philadelphia oh Jesus you guys
they do this for everything soccer yeah
not baseball baseball is kind of nice
here we go
baseball's a gentleman's sport
[Applause]
are you doing stage dives
[Applause]
dad this this looks like a riot like a
straight-up protest that's like a
government takeover opposing team like
member some athlete on the other team
they're just like I just got hired to do
a job like Tom Brady's like I don't care
I just got hired to play I'm not
attached to that number no no I know
he's he's happy just kissing his baby
boy in the mouth for 13 seconds he's
good he does yeah basically yeah it's
like yeah the 11 year old kid
oh my god 11 yeah so that gives like 11
years old right and yeah I forgot what
segment was but he's getting like a
massage or some [ __ ] his kid comes in
and then he gives his dad a peck right
like on the lips which it was cool walks
away he goes that's not long enough and
the kid comes over he kisses for like a
solid 3 4 seconds and then he walks away
and everybody's like what the [ __ ]
dad and kid right yeah but he's also
he's also almost 12 years old
but there's context maybe the kid
stopped kissing him so he's so Tom
Brady's like hey give your dad a kiss
more I built the back story don't worry
maybe that is the back story hey son
where's the tongue where's the tongue
but basically what it was it's cool I
just kind of creeped me out a little bit
like that's interesting it's very
interesting that is very interesting you
should watch the clip is hilarious I'm
gonna invent a new kiss if when I had
kids is gonna be over the nose yeah I've
had like some nice tea where someone's
like duh I hate that feeling of like the
lips right here all right so what
psychologists and sociologists have
studied here they're saying that
there are many factors as to why people
write so first one is intense fan
identification with the team like by
them being part of the team and like by
then it's tribalism yeah and then
another one is behavioral changes when
people become part of a mob they feel
like they're anonymous they can just get
away with anything because there's a big
group of people true
another reason is strong psychological
and physiological responses when your
team wins or loses so for example
they've studied fans of teams that have
won and they find that there's more
there's higher testosterone levels and
safe testosterone that's what the game
the fans that lost like the team lost
they have less testosterone and then
they also like they tend to eat the fans
at one the team one they tend to eat
healthier and like they're just way more
like positive and they have a higher
office all the chicken wings on the
floor can be celery sticks yeah and like
the people that lost like they attend to
it I got to lose and eat the [ __ ]
chicken wings end yeah there's a little
more depressed and like if they if you
ask them like oh would you be down to
ask that girl out though the ones that
lost will most likely be like nah she'll
say no anyway like they're not very
optimal or self-esteem shame that's
crazy it's like going through war yeah I
know it is so no Patriot fans are
getting [ __ ] that night then what yeah
that's funny I did come across the
headline that the Patriots fans that
they they just ended up watching porn in
me I'm like the porn is pretty
depressing
Angles fans just freaking had their way
that's just pure testosterone like they
don't have nowhere to put it they just
gotta get it out I'm after they win like
nuts slave up [ __ ]
it's so weird though like when you
identify with like a person or sport
like their victory literally feels like
yours you do feel it though yeah
remember when we were watching the
McGregor & Diaz fight and then when Diaz
why I felt like I finally beat him
would you flip over your [ __ ] Jean
Georges st. Pierre came back and he beat
his being I actually teared up I didn't
know why I was crazy yeah I don't know
what Dan that's why people raped and
pillaged so after you took over their
town and then you eat all their food
it's like it's the spoils oh [ __ ] it's
like hardwired into us it's so hard for
me to watch like organized sports not
because of how clearly like it's rigged
to sometimes you know especially with
like boxing like referee every thing you
know I mean it's so hard to watch that's
why I like UFC because you're just
getting your face [ __ ] smashed in
even that can't be rigged to you though
yeah but dude I want to see this in the
most docile sports in the most like golf
or something I want to see them [ __ ]
like crazy huh like ping pong ping pong
yeah like they'd start toys she knows
life with a lot of ladies I think he had
little mini riots I want to see like the
whole country club right that might like
throw chairs out the window holy [ __ ]
they do they go like this yeah the the
researchers here they're saying that
usually the people that tend to
participate in these riots are young
Caucasian frat boys frat boys I wonder
why or minorities no they're just gonna
get shot at they're like we can't be
doing these things so so minorities like
they protest and flip over cars for like
rights and then why people they protest
for teams buddy like [ __ ] named Chad
yeah you would go outside instead of
building on fire [ __ ] flip over cars
I get fear of minority but that's a
recipe to get shot yeah I'm tired I'll
stay here yeah keep grinding yeah let's
pick another super wall here though did
you guys see Kevin Hart try getting on
stage no I'll show you guys the clip
there Kevin he's got so job was like mad
drunk during the game dude it was
[ __ ] hilarious
is he from telly yeah he's from Philly
you got his head down baby they wouldn't
let about it
it is also next to football players do
you know they were I forgot what stayed
with their world corny but Kevin Hart
comes on he has the mic right yeah yeah
watch it is he standing up you know the
guy sitting that guy was standing
another guy sitting down afterward when
he was driving home this is what he
posted on histogram
not driving driven home in a Super Bowl
yeah I'm still alone now I got to be up
there with my city who gives a [ __ ] go
Eagles no it was her that's dumb when
you sobered up a little bit here I
thought thanks so much man that's just
so hilarious too drunk Kevin Hartz one
of the funniest he's ever seen in my
life he don't give a [ __ ] that's just
hilarious dude I bet you he's hella fun
when he's drunk may I don't want to be
that drunk yeah I can take my alcohol
you got a drink together on know what
you know what happens I just
SiC oh you at the asianglow no I don't
even get the glow I just get the fever's
drink and I go why did I drink
what are you drink Alizee what are you
drinking like I [ __ ] drink the neck
of it and I get a headache and I puke
and then like I'm suffering dang yeah it
sucks I don't even get to the drunkness
have you tested out like different
different yes because different alcohols
Captain Morgan work no champagne gave me
a headache
Captain Morgan captain okona original
space yeah just regular okay yeah and
then um I did that twice and I finally
felt what buzz feels like oh that's nice
that old dancing all night happy next
time and then I did it again
and I puked all over and I was like and
they're like maybe you need something
lighter so I got like a wine cooler
drank the whole [ __ ] thing do you eat
before you drink cause you're not here
maybe you're some exempt tea no I just
think I'm allergic to alcohol cuz one
time I drank wine and I was like I can't
breathe I don't know what's going on
it's just suffering I am I did the 23
Amir says that oh okay there's no like
going around and like with the Pepsi or
whatever maybe but it's almost like hey
you know it's not good for you already
so why are you forcing it ah you know me
I'm an addict for a lot of things so I
probably shouldn't get into it that's
true I can't smoke weed I was so jealous
of people smoking weed they look so
chill and relaxed it doesn't show me out
at all I just get like really scared and
my heart beats really fast and I think
everything's gonna kill me yeah it's
really bad
[Music]
[Music]